here on the show we love to shine a
light on people who are working hard to
help other people
my name is carlos aponte i am the
founder and executive director of we
love philly we love philly does its best
to turn the community the city of
philadelphia into the classroom for high
school aged youth i got fed up with
trying to teach the regular curriculum
to the students growing up as a post
2000 baby like a lot of these students
are they're constantly on their cell
phones they're constantly interacting
with media and the traditional classroom
setting is no longer a place where most
students feel stimulated
i decided to take students out of the
classroom to give them that real world
experience and try to peel their faces
away from themselves for a little bit
students have gone and volunteered in
over 50 non-profit organizations we
cleaned our community for 12 straight
hours and we raised
dollars for a school bus that students
use as a mobile education vehicle we're
literally creating the education that
our youth want so taking their voices
listening to them
co-collaborating with them watching them
grow and take ownership there's really
no place that i'd rather be
[Music]
we just love everything that you're
doing and we're not the only ones by the
way gateway wants to give you ten
thousand dollars
continue all the good work that you are
doing thank you so much
thank you
my name is latonya navon and i am from
the bronx i am the proud owner of bronx
bound books a bookstore on wheels right
now the bronze only has one brick and
mortar bookstore i believe a bookstore
should be a staple in every community
sometimes the kids in the box don't have
access to books until they are in the
school building my mission is to make
book ownership accessible and affordable
i purchased an old bus and took out all
the seats and flooring and converted it
into a beautiful bookstore on wheels
we sell books at weekly farmer's markets
we visit schools
we go to shelters and we also host
various book drives there's such a huge
misconception about the people in the
bronx not wanting to read
i see young people all the time get
excited about reading some kids come on
and they can't believe there's so many
books others come on and just sit down
and just want to read they think it's a
genius idea for a bus to be turned into
a bookstore bronx phone books feels like
more than a dream come true it's more
than i could have ever imagined it to be
i wake up every day thinking of new ways
to improve how to serve my community
and to make my dream even bigger
well we told the publisher um
a kid's company about all about you and
they're going to give you 5 000
worth of empowering educational kids
books wow
and then i'm gonna match it and give you
five thousand dollars just to enable
whatever you see fit and how to spend
that thank you so much
thank you so much
so beyond the crisis really has to do
with kind of going beyond the crisis
because
we all know about the current pandemic
and how like what that caused for a lot
of people and how that was
such a huge issue but food insecurity is
an everyday problem it's an ongoing
problem and we really wanted to address
that
on top of kind of
the exacerbated effects caused by the
pandemic so it was really that that kind
of pushed us to get started get working
i mean you guys are so amazing really
every word you're saying i'm just
hanging on it
and
you have helped over
a thousand
families
[Music]
we're so amazed by what you're doing and
then our friends at lundberg family
farms are donating ten thousand dollars
oh my god
non-perishable rice and snack items
and they just want to
[Applause]
you help brother appreciate it
[Music]